ó aqui à vista é magnífica othoniel por
que razão é que o terno stazo é só
descer logo no primeiro ponto
eu há alguns anos que vivia hotel em
dança bom tempo no local e linha e
alguma forma é o entre si e em fio e
orgulho que é uma coisa e raramente uma
pessoa pode ter com o site com o qual
não tem eu ia passar o excitamento
nenhuma de um mostrar como se estivesse
a falar alguma coisa que realmente
frente logo a mesma apesar de ser mãe e
azul conhecer e branco d
é claro que uma situação destas eu
gostaria imenso estar aqui é uma
celebração achou da condição mas não foi
desde o início e na região e vavá de um
conjunto só acho que está em trabalhar
hoje em dia vivemos muitos anos vai
dizendo coisas muito rápidas ea um
investimento muito grande um humano que
é para atingir a perfeição e se esqueceu
está quem há vários estudos nessa área
disse basicamente que nós temos um
especialista temos ter 10 mil horas de
trabalho aqui pessoas desabilitadas era
poder dizer que aquilo que nós ficamos
aqui e isso é bom e próximo a nós com
disponibilidade de vir aí a nossa mira a
nossa terra a terra que também tem uma
língua que é comum e e em nossa no
sentido é muito interessante
verificarmos que temos muitas pessoas
com 10 mil lojas trabalho
isso é um ato de amor sai japino sexo
que seja mas também é um ato de amor
isso que é grande natureza sexual
pelo menos a minha relação na minha área
com disciplinas que
de alguma forma tenha paginado eu também
tem um ato de amor ao rio que não se
entre outros físicos né nomeadamente
comer mas de passagem que temos essa
essa relação com o conhecimento o
conhecimento científico porque e aí foi
uma grande taça é o neuton não estou bem
mas fiquei em agradável - chocava com o
fax tamanho aí haver uma cultura
científica possível em um país onde nós
somos o elogio da cultura científica
como então temos aqui um dos capacidade
porque grande parte somos ao falarmos
português e quer dizer então que há
ainda aquela língua é inglês
nós também temos uma língua global
portuguesa em pouco tempo vamos em
fazermos coisas e de alguma forma o são
paulo se inspirarem ser inspirava por
essa essa situação
já o módulo aprendi tanta coisa e mandar
instituídas tem a cabeça em água e já
nem me lembro vai me acho que em alguns
casos eu peço pra confundir as coisas
cometia alguns erros português mas a
informação era tanta que esta coisa
devia ser feita no próximo
então eu aqui a tentar saber mas vi
algum móvel de algum modo a mim parece
que o tema que era um grande risco
porque geralmente os times ponto de
falar nós próprios dizeres porque temos
pouco investimento muitas vezes nós
próprios por isso acho eu essa leitura é
e eu penso que aqui ficou vai provar que
somos capazes de se outra coisa também
ficou provava que é possível mobilizar
no porto um jogo fantástico de souza daí
eu acho que o manuel ea equipa de
houston para vários
eu acho que o primeiro ponto é ter e
mesmo antes de fazermos uma breve
análise escrita com uma salva de palmas
para manuela
dora é agora a a acredito não concordo
com tudo o que disseram sobre quer andré
mas é este precisamente um bom espírito
que aqui está é debater as idéias sem
ter a necessidade de uma pessoa por um
pé à frente um pé atrás e ouvir as
pessoas que achou uma foi uma das
subidas das últimas coisas as minhas
últimas como tensas acre é essa que
também é ser surdo é para que o que não
é positivo muitas vezes também são os
surdos para que o que é positivo e isso
é complicado eu gostava imenso mandaram
para que nós queria ser um desastre que
o peso mais de alguns que o sistema
bancário estudo que está em minha visão
não admitirá mas aprendi imenso e vão
ter que pensar naquilo que aprendi é e
eu senti também é uma é uma foto de
sangue porque eu estando ligado à área
das tecnologias e dos computadores ea
matemática também como base de creme a
há muitos anos foi há 15 anos uma coisa
que chamava humanização das tecnologias
de informação e andaraí
provavelmente mais uma dezena de anos a
dizer que a tecnologia aproximar as
pessoas e que era neutra no sentido que
as pessoas é que fazem alguma coisa é ó
estamos a ver é e eu já tenho um aspecto
que estes estão agora dizer este tipo de
coisas
há 15 anos quando toda a gente dizia
para eu ter uma formação esquisita isto
é família etc enfim e ou cinto e isso é
importante
mais do que acha e esse tipo de
abordagem
acho eu é claramente uma mais valia uma
contenção lusitana
nós sentimos que temos essa esse feeling
iria alguma forma é que o que eu sentia
que é que
existe campo para uma pessoa fazer
coisas existem outras pessoas a fazer
coisas desse tipo tamanho equilíbrio
obrigado
[Aplausos]